hey guys Pete here just finished
watching the mr. robot two-hour series
finale and have to say that I really
liked how the story wrapped up I'm
feeling a lot of different things and
feeling compelled to write 3,000 words
about this right at the moment is not
one of them so this is gonna be a quick
recap reaction kind of thing where I
talk about how I interpreted the ending
season 4 episodes 12 and 13 for a story
that has kept us guessing the whole time
I feel like what happened was pretty
clear but there was a lot going on and
it's all sandwiched in between some
really emotional moments so I will recap
slash explain the ending as I see it
talk about the moments that stood out
for me and how the series played out in
relation to my expectations and
expectations is where I'll start because
coming into this I really didn't know
what to expect anymore
I really didn't like the idea of a
simulation which I talked about in my
last recap video I never really got into
the ideas that white roses machine might
be real and there were some kind of
sci-fi explanations coming but part of
what I loved about the show was the fact
that all of that stuff was somewhat
believable like anything could happen
those things that sound that outrageous
sound that equally possible in the end
we find out that everything was related
to what's going on inside Elliott's head
the final twist was that Elliott we've
been watching he was the other one he
was the mastermind which we'll get into
later and that we never actually met the
real Elliott so episode 11 closed with
White Rose committing suicide and
activating her machine we learn in
episode 12 that the alternate world we
visited wasn't actually the result of
that it was an illusion it was a world
that was made up to keep the host
Elliott busy and safe I'm mostly gonna
gloss over the first half of this
although it was definitely a great
episode of television the opening with
mr. Roboto playing was fantastic seeing
how all the irregularities in episode 11
were from this Elliott coming into the
illusion the recursive loop as mr. robot
describes him grappling with the idea
that he could take over this life that
he could be with Angela he could be
happy all of that worked really well
there were some genuinely funny moments
in episode 12 but the real answer
started to come in
second half of the finale through an
alternate form of krysta we learned
about the personalities and how his di D
works she says in order for you to fully
hear the truth first we need to discuss
Elliott's dissociative identity disorder
we hear again that the first personality
was created the day Elliot jumped out
the window
that was the protector personality the
one that Elliot created to replace his
father to protect him from intolerable
situations later he created a mother
personality she was the persecutor she
blamed Elliot for the abuse that
happened to him and insisted that he
needed to pay for it after that came a
younger version of Elliot she describes
this as someone he merged to handle the
abuse he couldn't tolerate and she says
basically that he created his own family
of sorts Elliot looks at the camera and
says I guess she doesn't know about you
bringing us to the forefront his friend
Christa then does the same she looks
right into the camera
and says that she knows us as well the
boyars who think they aren't a part of
this despite being here for all of it
goes on to explain that the other
identities thought they knew all about
its personalities but this other one
came up not too long ago and that's the
one we know in the series the hooded
Elliot that we've followed she says I
know why you did it your heart was in
the right place he wanted to shelter him
which is why you changed his past but it
was his future you really wanted to
protect that's why he went through such
great lanes to take out all the evil
that surrounded him in the real world so
you formed eff society you loved him so
much he wanted to save the entire world
so you could make it better for him no
matter the cost that's why you hit him
here turning his harsh reality into a
fantasy trapping him in an endless loop
to keep him safe until you were ready
and this is where we get the idea of
what's been going on the show goes out
of its way
explains it three different times
through mr. robot Angela and Krista
Krista it only comes in after the other
two have already explained that just to
make sure that we understand there's
several flashbacks that show us the
clues that were there so just to recap
there are five different alters the
protector which is mr. robot Elliot's
mom who is the persecutor
younger self us or the voyeurs and the
mastermind which is the Elliott that
we've been following throughout series
the mastermind was a reaction to all of
Elliott's rage and he also became the
personality that wanted to shelter
Elliott he changed things in the past so
that his father was his friend and not
this monster that was his abuser and
after he did that he went on to try to
change the world at this point of the
story he succeeded F Society they stole
the money and redistributed it whiterose
is gone the project is destroyed the
mastermind at this point has been
successful so the only thing that's left
for him to do is to let go and that
proves to be difficult we see the
mastermind wake up in a hospital room
Darlene is there waiting she reassures
him that everything we saw over the last
four seasons was in fact true F Society
v nine robbing the dais group
it all happened white rose is dead and
the mastermind explains to her that he's
only a part of Elliott which she already
knows this is where I got that
overwhelming feeling of enjoyment that
I've gotten from mr. robot so many times
that this story was telling me something
that I wanted to hear in the boardroom
we see the alters together and the
monologue was good but as the mastermind
accepts that his work is done and heads
down the hall to join the others in the
movie theater it hit me that SML had
taken me to a place I didn't know I
needed to go at the end of the day it
was a story about healing and overcoming
the things that life puts in our way
watching the mastermind come to terms
with the fact that he's only a part of
Elliot but he's done his part to make
the world a better place there's
optimism in that that I enjoy because at
times it's been a little bit hard to
imagine that there could be an ending
that would be satisfying in that way
I loved the closing sequence in the
movie theater and I loved that it was
Darlene there waiting for him when the
host Elliot wakes up Darlene said that
she bailed because she couldn't
understand what Elliot was going through
and that felt very true to life for me
of course she came up short in their
relationship she's human but she's there
for him at the end and she gets to
deliver the hello Elliot as we say
goodbye to our friend so to be clear my
understanding of the end is this we've
never met the ho
Eliot or the real Eliot we have followed
the mastermind which was the most recent
alder that came into existence to
shelter Eliot from the trauma he
experienced he created an alternate
place for Eliot that had everything he
needed to be happy except for Darlene in
the real world he set out to take down
Ecore and ultimately white rose and
everything that we saw happened in the
four seasons of mr. robot White Rose had
created the Deus group to consolidate
power and wealth and had a delusional
plan to change the world with the
machine that she built at the Washington
Township plan she killed herself after
turning the machine on because the
mastermind put her back against the wall
by stealing her money and exposing the
data screw he was able to stop the
machine by playing the game but not
before the plant was destroyed Eliot was
able to survive because the room they
met in was designed with special
shielding as protection from this type
of disaster with help from the other
alters the mastermind is able to realize
that he's only a part of Eliot and that
he has to let go so that the host Eliot
can return after he does that the real
Eliot wakes up with Darlene by his side
and he can now begin to move on does
this mean we saw a full integration of
all the alters I don't know and I don't
need to there are some things about this
ending that are open to interpretation
and I imagine how you feel about that
will decide whether you enjoyed it or
not for me it's somehow transcended the
potential cheesiness of the actual
things that was saying just be yourself
or just keep going is there but there's
also an idea that things are worth
fighting for
we live in a world where we're
constantly trying to be someone else or
being told we should be something else
and it can be easy to lose sight of what
matters connecting with the people we
care about and making things better the
best that we can when we can right there
with them we can't control how the world
reacts to that but we can continue to do
that because it's the right thing to do
and then maybe things get better and
maybe healing is possible and for me it
was a really fun ride I want to go back
and watch it again I've only watched it
once at this point so maybe I'll come
out and do a more detailed breakdown of
the last two episodes because there was
a lot to like but for now I just want to
say thanks to all of you guys who
watched the show with me and who've been
here following my channel say thanks to
Sam s male for making this great show
one
the things that I've always liked about
it is it takes chances and you could say
that ending with a big twist like this
and revealing that we never knew the
main character was a risk but I think it
paid off and I think it will go down as
a great finale I haven't looked at the
reactions too much but I'm sure some
people will be disappointed which is
inevitable but when you take chances
like this show does sometimes you're
gonna miss and I don't think they did
that with the finale so I'm curious to
hear what you guys think let me know in
the comments I can't wait to go back and
watch it again I can't wait to take a
little bit of time and go back and
re-watch the series knowing what we know
now I think it'll be a whole different
experience and it's one that I look
forward to if you didn't like it what
didn't you like about it what did you
want to see get answered that they can
get answered what way did you want to
see it go it's hard for me to imagine I
could see people being disappointed that
their theories didn't pay off or
something along those lines but I can't
really see this not being a satisfying
ending for the story that we just
watched so I'd be interested to hear
those opinions as well I think it did a
pretty good job of answering all the big
questions but I guess that doesn't mean
that all those answers would be
satisfying to everyone there's
definitely things I could nitpick that I
didn't like in each of the episodes
there were a few things that threw me
off in the moment but overall I think it
worked fantastically and I know that
people guess at the Eliott we were
watching was the other but it wasn't the
most popular theory by any stretch of
the imagination I wonder how the sci-fi
ending people feel about this a lot of
people really had that idea that it was
going to be a sci-fi that there was
gonna be alternate realities there was
gonna be simulations I wonder how this
sits with that crowd for sure but it had
a little bit of everything and like I
mentioned before I mean this has taken
us to some dark places so it's nice that
there is some hope and some optimism at
the end of the story please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you have not done that
already thanks for watching guys it's
been a great ride I will talk to you
soon